ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
that was when you found out
[Music]
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spider-man
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every
universe
hello peter
you're not peter parker
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so
scooby-doo this crap you know oh this is
kind of your mess i know a couple of
magic words myself starting with the
word please
please
scooby-doo this crap
you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spider-man
it's their fate
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
look there has to be another way there
isn't
they're a danger to our universe
[Music]
you're not gonna take this away from me
you're struggling
to have
everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
[Applause]
what's happening they're starting to
come through
and i can't stop them
december 17th exclusively in movie
theaters tickets on sale november 29th
spider monday
[Music]
you